hey leute und herzlich willkommen zur
zweiten folge von fifa ultimate team der
aufstieg bis ins ultimative team bis
werte geile 11 haben also ich mache das
erst mal so lange wie ich begann tief ab
wie ihr bock zum aufnehmen habt uns
weiter kam ja fragen mobiler hotspot
blablabla naja egal jedenfalls wird ich
sagen wir nehmen heute mal das deutsche
team in der liga eins also ich bin die
liga eins erst mal zu ende was wir
danach machen ist noch unklar
ihr könnt mir natürlich immer ideen in
kommt da beschreiben was ihr so denkt
wie ich so demnächst teil spielen soll
wenig verpflichten soll und was dich
dann sonst alles machen soll
ich schaue mal kurz ich habe übrigens
packs gezogen und zwar habe ich unter
anderem gezogen neven subotic den ich
hier gerade habe und auf die ich sehr
stolz bin
robert lewandowski finde ich sehr sehr
geil dass ich den gezogen habe ich habe
allerdings erstmal den özil im sturm
und ich würde sagen das team an sich
steht eigentlich haben alle eigentlich
verträge ich habe die verträge übels
ausgebaut ihr seht dass hier 32 spieler
noch 49 der özil hat noch 34 57 38 der
tat auch noch 30 der jogi löw team habe
ich mir für dings verpflichtet für 94
spieler der schon mehrere objekte gar
nichts ja okay gut jedenfalls will ich
sagen dass deutsche das deutsche team
jetzt und spielen da jetzt mal mit in
liga eins wir euch ändern können in der
letzten folge pire das englische team
genommen ein erstes spiel mit dem
englischen team 3 2 gewonnen ganz ganz
knapp war aber noch in ordnung also
kommt man man konnte sich sehen lassen
beim dsc
wir haben den gegner dominiert werden
glück dass der gegner nicht mehr tore
gemacht hat
aber wir spielen mal gegen werder bremen
ich verstehe mich jetzt hier überhaupt
noch so ein manual zeichen ab wollen
eigentlich alle sachen im bayern spiel
kaufen ihr wisst ich bin bayern fan und
auch ein deutsches team hat mandzukic im
sturm welcher allerdings nicht allzu
teuer ist tim wiese ist im spiel gut
ganze jetzt ist gut die formation das
auch gut die ist echt super die hab ich
damals auch mal gespielten das war mir
dann zu teuer
chemie hat er hunderte okay was alex
ferguson als trainer ich weiß garnicht
müssen einfach mal schauen was daraus
wird werder bremen
im old trafford er hat das old trafford
stadion ich bin hier gast also ich hab
übrigens wembley das habe ich eine
gefahr
es gibt immer so ein paar arten von fifa
gegen klein sind anfang total vorsichtig
schauen erst mal so und die anderen
sowie der hier die sind total aggressiv
setzt die machen erst mal quatsch ihr
gehen auf den man drauf und versuchen
den unter druck zu setzen mit sofort und
der ziemlich gerade richtig offensiv
das heißt ich muss darauf achten alter
luxury lifestyle vorteil oder so der
mich damit kann man schon mal gelb geben
wird sagen ich das ganze hier erstmal
auf sehr defensiv weil der typ auf jeden
fall mehr als sehr offensiv erscheint
aufgepasst von naldo an der stelle
das heißt wir müssen auf jeden fall
aufpassen das ganze nicht bornhofen
rennen mit seiner seiner ganzen
interviews stick war ich hatte ja so
dass diese immer so spät reagiert das
war guter pass von naldo geht einfach
mal drauf ist war so klar dass der typ
in der mitte zu ja schon vor sagt alter
warum geht der darauf wartet was das was
man mit einem englischen team ja mit
meinem deutschen team einspielen und
zwar ist das die sache dass ich ja viele
neue spieler gezogen habe unter anderem
bösen und so weiter seitdem habe ich ja
nicht mehr wieder gespielt vista online
ich wollten trick machen und dann
vergessen das haus zu betreten
also l2 machen jetzt auch mal hohem
druck auf ihn
wie kommt damit zurecht sagt bei
verlässt gebe ich ihm den ball haben die
ihr denn alle verpassen werte - 5 oder
was komisch nein nein nein nein nein
okay gut ein bisschen klasse ballannahme
klasse klasse gekämpft super özil nein
spiel schneller
das waren das waren vor
da nix mein gott soll die scheiße klasse
subotic super gemacht also ich muss
sagen mir ab der komplette richtig
reagiert mit klar mit dem ganzen druck
den wir aus ihm als wirklich bisher
super gemacht schlecht dabei schlechter
pass es ist eigentlich wenig ihr habt
genug als auch schnell habe ich den
speed bumps glaube ich geben muss jetzt
aufpassen da passt oben ja seid ihr also
habe ich eigentlich darauf gesetzt ist
ihnen denn verteidiger mein gott unnötig
gute klären traf heute im zentralen
mittelfeld kann ich übrigens nur
empfehlen klasse gemacht von allen
beteiligten blaszczykowski nun wieder in
die mitte wo sie nun wieder nach oben
nein eutern ist der abgefälscht oder
bekommt wieder eine freundesanfragen ach
verdammt naldo ist besser im
kopfballduell mit kopf verloren
denkste affeley
acom schwieriger kann es auch mal ein
bisschen was pfeifen hier dabei nicht
mal warum wirft er sie denn vom ball weg
verstehen der typ ist auch ein bisschen
mitdenken mandzukic ist nicht so ganz
der schnellsten und jetzt willkommen
gegen den neben subotic in abschaffen
nein da durch zu viel nachgedacht super
cluster gemacht ich dachte so bis zum
ende durch gehen und unter noch geräte
mit salto hinten dran und toren alles
euro sicher und weg übrigens immer mit
torwart die bälle weg hauen
auch wenn er sagt ich gehe aber immer
mit torwart so ein bisschen ist blöd
also einfach nur im ag immer sofort weg
schied mit torwart da können schon mal
ein paar doofe situation bei rumkommen
sage ich euch und das sage ich aus
erfahrung du also ich hab mir nicht an
dazu oder wert ist ein aufruf spielten
doppelpass 100 meter hoch ist einfach
abwarten schauen was der gegner macht
und jetzt ja ok
den haben wir locker dann habt ihr den
quasi besser unter kontrolle
hahaha erholt den torwart raus das
verzerrt sehr blöd online und dann war
er wieder im tor da war er wieder im bau
irgendwie habe ich das gefühl wir stehen
sehr offensiv dafür dass wir auf sehr
defensiv stehen schön schöner pass
es beginnt die zeit wo ich dann also
umlauf und mehr an sie denken wo kann
ich jetzt durchgehend okay ich versuche
einfach zu flanken
und das kann doch nicht sein alter was
sind das für ein pech da rollt der ball
auf die linie dann heute den weg das ist
echt jetzt glück seinerseits also
eigentlich jetzt schon 1 0 stehen müssen
eigentlich aber deshalb fußball da
passiert manchmal nicht zu dinge da
denkst du dir wie konnte das passieren
besonders ärgerlich ist es wenn man
selber eine großchance hat man weiß man
ist der bessere von beiden
weil der andere einfach immer das
gleiche macht beziehungsweise nichts
kann und dann schießt der anderen dem
moment tor sabrina nein enemy noch mit
man mich so aufregt vor allem ich weiß
immer wo die hinspielen aber trotzdem
kommen die bälle von ihm immer an sich
fast immer meistens kommt so der letzte
ball dagegen nicht an
so wie das jetzt super gemacht von elia
kann ich übrigens nur empfehlen halte
ich als lm glaube ich in meinem team
auch lauf doch mit amber hambach hambach
klasse war gut dass der abgefälscht und
warum mit der db trier ich habe
eigentlich geschlossen volk zu schießen
antäuschen mist jetzt haben wir jetzt
bitte bitte bitte werk wasser sehr schön
gemacht
ich muss ja wirklich nur lob aussprechen
für meine abwehr hören das nicht aber
die ganze spielweise gerade ist echt
super also das team passt so wie es
zurzeit ist klasse von online sagt er
steht jetzt ganz freie härchen an nicht
angenommen und dann ja okay es damit
glück dass halbzeit war weil da unten
ist einer gestartet 0 0 gegen sv cbn
also ich würde sagen ungefähr
gleichwertig mehr chance auf jeden fall
mehr ballbesitz er allerdings mehr
zweikämpfe gewonnen
also mir kam es so vor als wenn er
besser gewesen wäre
aber okay scheiße das war unnötig
geglückt
er setzt den ball ins feld bringen und
die renten
nein auf verdammt kommt das nicht wieder
so aktion wenn er da jetzt ein tor macht
dann weiß ich okay so was machst du nie
wieder und dadurch lernt man quasi
fehler
dadurch lernt man was man auf jeden fall
nicht noch mal machen dann wächst du
dienst aus schickt haben wir haben wir
haben wir klasse super gemacht dass
interaktion die muss man einfach mit dem
solche zweikämpfe und jetzt konnte ein
super klasse pass sehr schnell alter was
soll das da hat er mich doch einfach weg
das deck hat auch mal eine karte geben
der schildert ich teste jetzt mal eben
was ein guter schuss definitiv ja das
war auch klasse kopfball muss ich sagen
super bälle übrigens die hier auch kommt
auch aus komischen positionen spielen
und das war auch klasse raus wir weisen
mit dem ich direkt nehmen
ich dachte wahrscheinlich schon zum
unterbewusstsein ach das ist eh ab so
kann es jetzt noch ein bisschen faxen
machen
nein das war das war richtig dumm
wir waren das sehe ich gar nicht ein typ
mit u das spiel wird ausgeglichen das
sage ich mal
klasse herausgespielt auf jeden fall
schießt einfach mal acht mann habe ich
vergessen er einst zu drücken
richtig toren gehen ja fast immer rein
wenn man von außen in die mitte zieht
und damit der einzige winkel schlenzte
das machen sich sehr auf die spieler
endlich geklappt sehr oft und jetzt
kannste mir wahrscheinlich dass 10
gerade das war es ist wirklich eine
gegenseitige chancenverwertung ich sage
ich mal also unterschiedlich nicht
unterschiedlich viele chancen sondern
das gegenseitig am zug mann ist falls
sie erst kommt wer da an
das sind so sachen besser das sind faul
sie hat nicht verschuldet das war dann
irgendwie einer von den anderen spielern
dafür kriegt dann voll zu gerechnet sehr
schöner pass sehr schön vor allem kuba
ist sehr schnell schneller als die
anderen kann jetzt vorbei gehen und das
müsste dass einzelne das ist das dann
schaltete sich ihr ausgehen dass einer
explodiert
in ihm leben vorbei diese schnellen
einwürfe da kann sich nicht darauf
einstellen
danke was los ist den ball
ich versuche jetzt mal einen einwurf so
oft nicht mehr das vorgestellt hat also
von den pässen und alle möglichen sachen
besser er läuft daher der kolonien leben
vorbei
euro
manchester united steht unter druck
also contest sekunden von united fc
kommt es ist ja zu deutsches team mache
ich denn hier so einfach mal ein
bisschen ruhe jetzt ruhe reinbringen und
passt den ball dann komm jetzt mal ein
bisschen ruhe hier reinbringen so
hintenrum jetzt wieder nach vorne
es sind sie die nadelstich vista das ist
ein super pass und den krieg ich nicht
mehr so erstmal ein bisschen mehr druck
zu machen
vorhin auch so sagen jetzt gehen wir mal
ein bisschen das alles ruhiger sein
alter wieso nimmt er den ball der nicht
an
das ist ein lewis holtby der kann bald
auf drei meter flachen nicht an denen
ich glaub sehr wohl nicht die sachen die
verstehe ich einfach nicht bei diesem
spiel
das ist ein einbruch schon längst um aus
sondern mich verpackt aber jetzt ey das
kann ich sein warum funktioniert die
geräte dann nicht wenn er die flaggen
ein bisschen besser geschlagen hätte
denn erstens 10 gewesen ist kann ich
euch versprechen hoch und heilig
so jetzt jetzt jetzt jetzt jetzt
vielleicht eine der letzten chance für
mich in diesem spiel wenn da konnte ich
nicht drauf
nein und dann hält er den kurzzeitig
denkt so oder so wir stehen immer noch
auf diesen defensiv deswegen euch dann
zwei leute vorne
das wetter tüftelte situation der seit
dem fall machen könnte natürlich
versucht dass man nochmal mein gott
alter wachsen geiler schuss und was eine
geile parade
dahinter steht einer ganz hinten alter
form nimmt ihr denen alle direkt und
wollte ich gar nicht mit den haben bei
den haben die haben da der preis hoch
der was hätte ich nicht mit dem
gegründet scheiße nein nein
haut den ball noch weg jedoch darauf
jedoch drauf alter was der gibt elfmeter
was kann ich denn dafür hallo ich bin
gegen ihn gegen gelaufen den typen
konnte ich nicht mal steuern ja wie
behindert ist das denn bitte
komplette spiel ich habe da milliarden
von chance sie nutzt kein bisschen
der krieg so einen verdammten scheiß
elfmeter da macht ihr noch rein jetzt
kein unentschieden das schaffe dann
werde es aber mehr als unverändert das
kann ich so sagen wenn er spielt den
ball auch einfach nur noch nach vorne
schnell schnell
ich weiß nicht mal esswein bringen
besonders ein schneller mann so für die
letzten vier minuten
da hält er dem dann geht er am pfosten
echt glaubst du wohl nicht spielt den
ball raus
nein electric sich da wieder zu viel da
kann doch nicht sein dann hält er den
jetzt hält er hier alles so wie das
jetzt ein ganz cooler und bellt den ball
einfach mal für zehn jahre lang der hand
jetzt kriegen wir schon das zweite gut
abseits
bis bald nein
schnappt euch doch ändert kann nicht
wahr sein los adler kommen
okay vielleicht die letzte chance jetzt
alle nach vorne
oh mein gott es kann nicht sein ach du
scheiße nein das war die letzte chance
glaube ich dass war online ist das
behindertenwerk richten foulelfmeter
macht den rhein
also das war jetzt echt unfair egal man
spannendes spiel auf jeden fall wer am
ende gewinnt mit 683 okay ich habe
allerdings auch sie passt eigentlich man
das regiert aber auf schade dachte
machen jetzt die komplette saison ohne
niederlage
ok cool ultimate team mit geladen blabla
13 4 bis 1 im buch freigeschaltet wird
das für mit dem boost okay der neue dann
ja okay ich würde sagen dass war es erst
mal für die zweite folge fifa ultimate
team zusammen mit mir ja ich würd sagen
beim nächsten spiel nehmen wir dann mal
die englische mannschaft wieder mit der
deutschen hat zwar ganz gut geklappt
weil mit der englischen was besser ich
nehme dann die einfach mal und ja dann
will ich sagen sehen wir uns in der
nächsten folge und ich werde jetzt nur
noch eben einen vertrag ab weil er ein
gott ja der ist schon sehr gut
na ja ich würde sagen ihr seid beim
nächsten mal leute wie immer bewerten
nicht vergessen daumen hoch wenn es euch
gefallen hat und wir sind wenn es mal
jesse